what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey Jay Washington is
here mr. Jay Washington on Twitter and
Instagram trusty sidekick podcasts go
over there it's everywhere on the
internet it's everywhere everywhere
everywhere so you can think of it's
there every place you can download
something including form okay I I've
seen you what we're gonna talk about
today is it's making the news everywhere
I even got an oil change today it was on
Nam ABC News this is a huge ordeal
everyone's posting about it JJ Abrams is
directing Star Wars Episode nine I
cannot think of a more bland choice it's
called the plan is safe yeah I don't
like that that's Kathleen Kennedy like
because Kathleen Kennedy has basically
told everybody you gotta go through this
format when you're doing the Star Wars
films if you try to deviate from what we
have set for you again that's why Lord
Miller had gone from the Han Solo film
clearly that's why Colin Trevorrow was
gone now you see I felt like okay JJ
Abrams did a decent job with the force
awakens and I really did feel that I was
I wasn't like hey like oh it's exactly
do hope I thought it was a good set up a
good way to start a new trilogy that's
fine and then when they got Ryan Johnson
I was like oh here we go now we're gonna
take it in a new direction so I'm really
excited for Ryan Johnson's Star Wars
movie but then to take it with JJ Abrams
who's known to kind of just like his
trailers open turn those movies others
look like they're gonna be this super
inventive creative this is like either
pretty simple it's pretty conventional
yeah
like these Spielberg asked the problem
is you have the older fans of Star Wars
and a newer fans
mm-hm and that's where the clash is
coming in for in regards to warning
newer innovative directors because of
course Rian Johnson's gonna do something
different but maybe not as different as
we think because he has to have followed
that same parameter or I'll see what I
gotta find people are like let's just
let these new directors have it and
which is true you should let these new
directors come aboard and bring their
own creative visions but that hammer
that's been let down right there
Lucasfilm like this is what it is
you don't do it this way no matter what
so that's why you go back to JJ Abrams
again he's already did episode 7 why not
just come back to episode 9 I just don't
see him doing something that's gonna be
entirely like invent I was excited
I've been excited for and I like the
idea of getting a different director for
each one of this I believe the trilogy
and to go back to the guy who got blamed
for just you know do a green cheetah
with you I saw force awakens I was like
similar backlash for into darkness with
Star Trek yes yeah you know yeah snark
sugar new darkness was his direct sequel
system and it was like this ain't
exactly the most inventive thing in the
world a lot of points from and I'm like
this guy's great at omage you know like
we did with super 8 at the same time I'm
like this could have been a much more
exciting choice again for a direct I
feel like we're just not gonna get
something that's super exciting as we
want it to be you know it's like calling
tomorrow a Jurassic world I wasn't too
excited for Colin Trevorrow tomorrow and
like I said I like what JJ did with
episode the force awakens it's like when
they had his Lord and Miller I thought
that was great and they get raw Howard
to do what the studio's want him to do
and that's all this feels like now I'm
like Nana this is Star Wars is becoming
like studio movie although it still
could be good I do like rogue one I do
like force awakens but even road one I
thought was more ballsy yeah yeah with
dark which is a surprise everyone are
you excited for JJ to do this or you
just kind
whatever as I mean know what hours I'm
into whatever category because again
he's done it he knows what they want we
should hear less controversy behind the
director situation yeah I think that's
what everybody wants if you don't make
these movies make these movies it's
already sad we're not gonna have Carrie
Fisher anymore
Mark Hamill eventually has to go yeah so
you gotta just take whoever you're gonna
have at the helm of this film and just
know what Kathleen Kennedy is doing cuz
that's it's all Kathleen Kennedy she is
the director at yeah she's the one who
says no it needs to be this yeah I think
JJ Abrams is going to do a good job
that's the thing I'm not saying here
going he's gonna do a bad job I just
yeah it's just like going to to to a
Baskin Robbins in ordering vanilla yeah
good I know this will be tasty what I'm
getting yeah exactly there's a lot more
interesting stuff around and not that
you have to like I get the the trouble
with this is that they do have like
they've got to keep their committee
overarching thing you know they gotta
manage a lot with star yes but at the
same time yeah it just seems like
getting directors who are a bit more
interesting is also part of the hype
train every response I've seen over this
choice has been okay
like we don't he'll do a fine job I
think the problem was when you already
put him at the helm of force awakens
yeah because when you right because well
you heard we're getting a new trilogy
you respect to something completely
differently like you said earlier as a
whole everybody was like this is just a
new hope yeah this is just a new hope
all over again and so had he not done
force awakens we might have been excited
exactly yes awakens it amidst some you
like oh my god JJ Abrams is doing a Star
Wars yeah this is great but then once he
did force awakens and we're like we've
kind of seen this move Mirai now on the
opposite side of this coin I do start to
wonder like how again if we're talking
on these terms you know maybe the
directors have a ton to do with how
these movies are gonna turn out because
there's also the scripts there's also
the write which he's also writing oh yes
he is writing this as well alright a
little bit I feel like JJ's a great set
up director yeah like as the mission
impossible franchise got reinvigorated
with Mission Impossible 3 that's when it
would totally start rebooting and then
he continued producing then we got Ghost
Protocol rogue nation with two different
directors and I thought those captain
getting better and I could give up
always good at getting the ball rolling
I don't think he's the best at like
keeping the ball is acute the lane I
feel like he's a good producer and to
put a finale stamp on the trilogy so who
would if JJ Abrams became producer of
episode 9 I would like to see like Brad
Bird do it that would be I think the
problem is the internet in the world
don't just want a decent movie this is a
disease in a way that's circulating
around all these big flagship properties
as we keep revitalizing our beloved
stuff we did it recently with alien
again and we keep doing with all kinds
of things now we've got things like
Marvel popping up and stuff where you
have these overarching committees
guiding stories at a certain point I've
begun to worry about the Star Wars
movies especially with the Han Solo you
know debacle and some of the
announcements they make going forward
I'm like there's got to be a point at
which these movies are gonna stop the
prequel trilogy didn't do so good so we
know that they're capable of having
subpar films and so now I'm kind of
worried about where Star Wars is gonna
head and if it's gonna head into a
homogenized territory because that's
what drove me up the wall about alien
covenant which is not the same kind of
movie but it's like this is a beloved
thing that people claim some people
claim is one of their favorite movies
and if we're gonna bring it we're
leaving it alive we're keeping it
yellowing and we're making more of them
and if we're gonna do that they have to
be like Star Wars has to be pretty great
because if it turns out bland after a
while that's about the most depressing
thing that can happen I think to
piggyback on yours and you said Star
Wars had three horrible fairy tales with
the prequels the problem was nobody
asked for let's just be honest no one
care to know the full origins nobody
cared about Anakin Skywalker as a kid if
we just saw what happened just straight
after uh returning the Jedi yeah great
because we wouldn't been soured by
prequels now you have force awakens
every website okay for the most part
decent episode eight that comes out this
year you like the trailer our last Jedi
are you like okay we'll see but you got
a different director and Rian Johnson
like I trust we'll see well Ryan
Johnson's like the thing I'm excited
about and he'd like me he's letting you
know like listen what was it something
like the whole don't watch don't watch
Oh watch trailers if you want to enjoy
this movie enjoy the movie don't watch
trailers which is why he's not being
brought back for episode 19 fired what
do you mean don't watch make these
movies to cut yeah we have you film all
of this stuff in two weeks just for
trail yeah we could take it out of
context and reveal too much yeah real
quick it never seemed to be prongs of
force awakens onset episode eight
doesn't seem to have any problems on set
a hammer anything about like there's
problems going on other than of course
the unfortunate passing and carry
fishing that the spin-offs are the ones
that tend to have like the major
problems everyone keeps getting worried
about that I'm sure this one will be
fine I just hope that if they want to
stick to like studio notes for this
trilogy okay whatever
I'm hoping that for their spin-offs at
least they're that are willing to be
more creative and willing to embark on
like crazy or types of execution like
what Phil Lord and Chris Miller probably
would a dumb and on so I just hope they
don't stick to the whole this is what
the character has to be and end up like
so we need to follow this formula you
can take you can take a character
different ways twists and turns
yeah till you get to where they are but
again episode 9 is like I think the
thing is we have to wait till eight
comes out first yeah more than anything
sure all of us is just like here we go
again
but we forgot that there's a film still
coming out this year we have to let it
happen first sure once it happens if you
look at it and you see that ryan johnson
has literally did Empire Strikes Back
you're like oh you know there's a path
yeah now you don't we already said
Episode seven is similar to a new hope
in Episode eight is Empire Strikes Back
you're like oh I can see the template
this is not gonna be good there's gonna
be a fire dance of Fame at the end of
mind I promise it's gonna be a ghost
yeah
you know that's we have to wait till
8:00 first and foremost if it is
completely different then that might be
like mm-hmm exactly
totally and I'm hoping for that on the
positive side that could be JJ's chance
to do something that isn't gonna be so
scrutinized for being so close to
something but yes maybe yes if eight
really trudges off in its own direction
which I feel like it should like if
we're gonna keep doing these movies we
should keep groundbreaking with them and
trying stuff because that's what the
original ones did in the first place
yeah what the spirit is if this is his
chance to come back and do like this is
my difference no my lower right I
learned my lesson from Star Trek and
from Star Wars The Force awakens I'm
gonna give you guys something a little
different I've already talked to
Kathleen Kennedy I had to kiss on the
neck you can't disturb me my kiss on the
neck we talked but you know you got to
do something to my hair it was weird it
was weird it was awkward we had we had
prunes and wine I don't know why we had
the combination very regular
historically they have to have an
understandable look let's do something a
little bit different that stays along
the line but isn't like a carbon copy
all right guys well how aren't you to us
below in the comments are you excited
for JJ Abrams to be returning if you are
who do you want to have been hired to
directing this so you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell - on Humphrey on Twitter Instagram
follow us at patreon.com slash the real
rejects become a parrot on and mr. Jay
Washington on Twitter and Instagram yes
trusty sidekick podcast since then
YouTube no just like time we're just
nice and patio is found yeah anywhere
audio sounds because I don't have I
don't have a great video capabilities
like these fellows do but yeah we need
more people you mean our mic in the 1up
box I mean it works perfectly it looks
like a great that's why you got to join
our